hello hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome to swamp sim I
can't even pretend not to know what in
the world this is about because
obviously right there shrek is love
shrek is life
this is shrek game and if you know the
Internet shrek is a well-respected
individual who has many Omar's to him
and his gloriousness made on the
internet okay oh it definitely teams
some things from the last time I loaded
this up not that I got very far fine
okay
if you didn't know it's kind of a
slender cloning that you're just
collecting one of eight eight different
why does shrek have a bunch Madero and
what's inside the punishment barrel I
don't want to know but I spy another
onion Oh joyous I don't know if I'm
supposed to follow the path or not but
there's an onion right over here oh it's
gonna be good I can already tell this
game it's gonna be great Oh what was
that all about
Shrek you feeling okay what weirds me
out is that there was another mode for
this game called ogre Drive why I
couldn't possibly imagine what that mean
for me as a player and as an individual
and a fellow Shrek lover
I mean shrek is love shrek is life and
don't think I haven't thought about
doing a dramatic reading of that one
shrek story am I supposed to go in here
oh oh no don't get what is that
oh my god
it is a girl mightiness himself
Oh what do I do these steps of game
supervise we have like a long time ago I
played Sponge Bob Slendy pants like back
when sledder was a big thing these games
came out faster and faster this is just
kind of ridiculous some of the concepts
to come out of it oh I don't know what
else to do donkey was back there really
bad Scottish accent I stole my Scottish
fans but everybody knows that my
Scotland I think this time I need to
follow the path a bit better because I
think the path leads me to the onions
properly whereas I was just doing it
stupid I'm not ready for you I'm not
ready for Shrek II okay okay stay on the
path I gotta stand up okay so I think
the onions only appear once I get the
one prior to it so I gotta I gotta
follow the set pattern or I'm never
gonna get out of here
good why is it gonna be in the outhouse
[Music]
got it this is hilarious and terrifying
all at once oh god he's faster now Oh
where do we go where's the next one I
don't see where the next one's gonna be
did I go the wrong way I'm just gonna be
wandering around for a long time lost in
the woods with Shrek coming after my bum
button I gotta be quick about these last
ones that can't be wandering around lost
or else he's gonna get me got it
xanax what I see it
oh shut up god damn that was tough
oh man how am I supposed to be able to
get away from that douche
Jesus why does that happen
okay seven seven seven seven seven okay
was that last one
was that last one maybe we got dead last
one come on give it to me give it to me
give it to me give it to me
I lied and I said I didn't get one from
the building I don't know if I go back
to it in time
[Music]
[Applause]
goddamnit didn't spawn in the house
before god damnit what is there not
gonna get me god dammit
[Music]
okay so I found that the last onions are
usually pretty consistent which means
that the final onion has to be somewhere
near that space because the seventh one
is almost always at the base of that
hill well I don't know what it means
after that but it is what it is okay
here we go the seventh one is always in
the same place I think I have an idea
where it's gonna send me next it would
make sense if I had to go back to the
beginning right that's what I do I know
you're gonna do I just gotta make it I
hope I got enough distance in between me
there but I don't know if I have enough
crap
every pitch movie baby in the [ __ ] I
can't do the words
I made it
cut seem very good
fine I am a rock star okay
that's a beautiful dancing track there
right so that was swamp sim that took me
a long time to figure out I don't know
why cuz I could have figured that out a
long time ago baby the way thank you all
so much for watching check out the other
videos that I've done that are silly and
ridiculous like this like SpongeBob's
lending pants those years ago too so
that was back when slender like first
came out it's ridiculous it's awesome
and also I'm gonna play slender Tubby's
3 which just came out so there you go
thanks again everybody and as always I
will see you in the next
[Music]
help